unser kollege sebastian geisler hat sich
intensiv mit dem thema befasst ja
sebastian man möchte fortschrittlich
sein in der regierung aber es gibt
natürlich auch viel kritik für dieses
neue gesetz warum ja ich würde sagen
diese kritik gibt es auch zu recht es
ist natürlich so dass ist das phänomen
der transsexualität gibt und der
intersexualität es gibt aber natürlich
auch männer und frauen das ist so das
wird weiterhin so sein die frage ist was
hinter jetzt mechanismen in diesem
gesetzentwurf die dafür sorge tragen
dass nicht jemand zum gericht geht und
über einen sprechakte man sagt also dem
er aber sagt ich bin jetzt eine frau den
eintrag ändern es den namen ändern lässt
und es gibt dann keine mechanismen die
das überprüfen ob das überhaupt
gerechtfertigt ist um eine [ __ ]
intersexualität überhaupt vorliegt das
heißt dieser gesetzentwurf macht
möglicherweise ein missbrauch dann
möglich und das sollte in einem
rechtsstaat natürlich eigentlich nicht
sein und das ist auch von der
ampelkoalition in diesem entwurf
eigentlich noch nicht schlüssig geklärt
natürlich auch fraglich warum jemand das
machen sollte das ist wahrscheinlich
wirklich auch die ausnahme wo sind noch
mehr kritikpunkte jetzt in dem neuen
gesetz ja beispielsweise beim thema
familienrecht es ist ja so dass
jugendliche ab 14 jahren jetzt auch
beantragen können sollen mit zustimmung
der eltern dass sie ihren geschlechts
eintrag ändern lassen dass ein junger
sagen kann ich möchte ein als medien
aufwachsen ich möchte rechtlich ein
mädchen sein das betrifft dann noch
nicht die anpassung möglicherweise die
geschlechtliche anpassung über eine
umwandlung am mond therapie und so
weiter das ist noch mal auf einem
anderen blatt sozusagen aber bisher war
so dass die eltern so etwas zu
entscheiden hatten jetzt ist es so wenn
die eltern da aber dagegen sind das kind
das aber trotzdem beantragt dass man das
familiengericht darüber zu entscheiden
hat um das ist natürlich ein erheblicher
eingriff auch in die elterliche
souveränität dem dem kind gegenüber oder
die eigentliche elterliche sorge nehmen
uns mal mit wie könnte das im alltag
aussehen zum beispiel auf öffentlichen
toiletten oder auch im sport ja auch das
ist ein großes problem und da war es
auch unsere familienministerin dieser
pause noch nicht so ganz wie man damit
umgehen soll was macht man denn jetzt
wenn beispielsweise einen mann der auch
der biologisch ein mann ist der
vielleicht auch noch als mann lebt der
aber seinen geschlechts eintrag hat
ändern lassen dass er künftig dann sehr
einfach möglich sein soll in einer
frauen um kleidung geht in den frauen
das sagen das möchte ich aber nicht so
möchte ich mich jetzt hier nicht
umziehen vor dieser person da gibt es
eigentlich da hatte sagte nun frau aus
trans personen oder trans frauen sind
frauen die frage ob das dann frauen in
einer solchen umkleide auch so sehen
oder ob nicht möglicherweise sogar ein
missbrauch dieses gesetzes vorliegt auch
das ist ein problem weiteres problem ist
durchaus
betrifft auch eine sehr interessante
rechtliche frage das sogenannte de-mail
wenn man eine person eine trans personen
anspricht unter dem namen unter dem sie
vorher bekannt war unter dem anderen
geschlecht das soll hier unter strafe
gestellt werden im sinne einer
beleidigung wie man ja auch nicht
einfach so menschen beleidigen kann ich
finde tatsächlich wenn man jemanden
bewusst mit dem falschen namen anspricht
um zu provozieren oder so das erfüllt
für mich durchaus den tatbestand einer
beleidigung das so weit würde ich da
durchaus mitgehen problematisch ist aber
ob es möglich aber so weit geht dass ich
nicht mal sagen darf mein nachbar lebte
früher als frau unter dem namen oder wie
so etwas ja auch er ist also ja also wo
ich ja auch sozusagen die realität
beschreibe bei das ja so ist im
rechtsstaat muss ist in einer
freiheitlich offene gesellschaft muss es
immer möglich sein die realität zu
beschreiben wenn das hier in irgendeiner
weise rechtlich eingeschränkt oder gar
mit einer geldbuße also strafbewehrt
sein sollte ist das ein großes problem
und ich glaube dass gerade da zum
beispiel auch aus der fdp die ja zur
ampelkoalition logischerweise gehört man
daher bauchschmerzen hat und dass da
nicht alle mitgehen werden und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass gerade das
ein punkt ist wo man vielleicht wenn es
jetzt um die tatsächliche ausgestaltung
und abstimmung des gesetzes geht das
noch mal aufstellt oder nochmal dran
geht also noch nicht wirklich ausgereift
dieser gesetzesentwurf besten dank
sebastian geisler dankeschön